floyd mayweather who comes out
as there is a huge controversy around
the basketball player kyrie irving
who won't get the vaccine he's being
benched now floyd mayweather comes out
he says hey buddy great job kyrie what's
up i know you're going through a lot
we had a chance to hang out in 2016 when
you represented america when you
represented the red white and blue
you only want to be treated fair you're
a great person great father
a great athlete
and you believe what you believe
america is the land of the free freedom
of speech freedom of religion and
supposedly freedom to choose
never be controlled by money i respect
you for having some integrity and being
your own man
a free mind makes his own choices and
his slave mind follows the crowd
stand for something or fall for anything
one man can lead a revolution to stand
up and fight for what's right one choice
one word one action can change the world
it's crazy how people
hate you for being a leader
i hope your actions
encourage many others to stand up
and say enough is enough
respect to you kyrie and power to the
people
now i love this message
i'm not gonna
flatter people though all right what
floyd mayweather just said is a bunch of
platitudes it's a bunch of slogans
enough enough is enough power to the
people
you're free be free right it's all this
really basic stuff that is not
particularly profound it's not deep
political
thinking
but i still love this message and i love
the courage that it is taking him
to stand up and say this and i think the
gop has a big lesson that it can learn
here which is when you were going out
when you were conveying a message i'm
not talking about when we have debates
i'm not talking about when we're
formulating our plan when we're
strategizing i'm not even talking about
on podcasts such as this or in think
tanks or in the room of advisors i'm
talking about when you are just
communicating
your plan for america
keep it simple buddy
be like floyd mayweather here
where he says what do we know what do we
know about the vaccine
it's experimental
it's
it has had side effects it has killed
people you say in rare cases but that's
why they pause the johnson johnson
vaccine because
people were dying from blood clots it
does entail risks all vaccines all
medical interventions entail risks and
for the vast majority of people the
coronavirus is just not that deadly it's
just not
that dangerous for for some people it is
for most people vast majority people
it's not
so
let's just say hey guys make your own
decisions hey be prudent hey guys we
have a tradition in america of people
making their own decisions on these
sorts of things
the democrats are going to say well
actually you know if you look at the
statistics and you look at the numbers
and then but and we know that the
scientists all say the backseat is
totally fine
yeah right but we know on a gut level
this is wrong
we know on a gut level when we listen to
the prime minister of new zealand say
she's going to segregate her citizens we
know that's wrong okay we don't we don't
like that we don't want that
keep it simple
yeah we want freedom stand up do what's
right enough is enough power to the
people i hear you i hear you floyd i
agree
i'm so glad you like that clip i like
that clip too but a lot of people i'm
sorry to say are not getting
notifications for these clips if you
want to get notifications ring the bell
subscribe more importantly head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play myspace xanga aol instant
messenger wherever you get your podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see
[Music]
[Music]
you